your ambassador your excellency thank
you for talking to us today first of all
our condolences for the loss of life the
huge loss of life on this aeroplane in
this tragic accident it seems in Tehran
the American Canadian British European
intelligence agencies are telling us
that this was shot down by the Iranian
military possibly by mistake and yet
this morning authorities in Tehran are
insisting this was not possible where is
the truth and how do you establish the
truth between those two positions the
truth should be authenticated and
concluded by the experts on the ground
not by some unidentified intelligence
officers who cannot accept any
responsibilities for any kind of
misrepresentation or misconception
because we are very sorry to say that
unfortunately the countries that have
been rushing to such judgments do not
have any access to the hard evidences on
the ground do they have the black box do
they have the voice recorder do they
have the in fact the wreckage of the
plane in their hands so on what just
what basis they are making such in fact
conclusions that that are in fact cannot
be verified at this moment based on the
international regulations there are
certain procedures that you should be
followed to have a conclusion about the
real cause of the incident and we have
in Iran established immediately in fact
a body to investigate that and we have
invited a lot of experts from the
concerned countries from Canada from
United States and the Ukraine of course
and the other expect experts to
investigate the the issue you say that
they are rushing to judgment but this
morning your own government
all doubt the possibility of a missile
strike how can they be so sure how can
your government be categorically sure
that it hasn't done this has been a
tragic mistake carried out by its own
military because they are attributing
that this so claimed mistake has been
done by our military so we are very
clear and confident about our military
and the missile if it has been involved
so we are in fact confident from outside
that there has been no missile launched
in that area at that time but we see in
this video a number of videos of what
looks like one light flying towards
another then a flash and then shortly
after that it's exactly the same place
you'd expect a missile strike to happen
very close to where the plane came down
have you seen those videos surely
they're already compelling isn't it
there are a lot of footage and such
videos that some some of them or
contradict nature there even there there
has been any video that the same model
of Boeing airplane has been set fire in
other countries so in fact we should be
very careful about not judging on a very
critical point on the on such videos
which we don't know about that
there in fact validity and if they are
very reliable sources so we should be
very very careful not to jump to any
judgments and let the experts see and in
fact verify first the black box which is
the the most important element to help
us to have this the full story and voice
recorder and in fact the the voice of
the captain also has been recorded and
we have the hard evidences on the ground
so these are the main elements that you
should be verified I talked about the
hard evidence on the ground the CBS film
crew has been there news crew there
today they said that it has been
bulldozed all the evidence used are
being cleared up there are scavengers
picking the scene apart there's no
cordon there's no security apparently
our investigation that's no way to
conduct the aftermath of a terrible
plane accident
are we in fact relying on the reporters
to have a judgment about a very
technical issue or we think we've seen
video we've seen film of builders can
you make a judgement you're Iranian
state TV we've seen bulldozers clear in
the area that doesn't normally happen
after a plane accident does it take the
accidents plane accidents or very
technical issue I cannot judge you
cannot judge reporters on the ground
cannot judge nobody can judge a foreign
minister or prime minister can judge
cannot judge on the issue that the
experts or the people who can go and
find the black box and the hard
evidences on the ground there for
example the technical team of Canada
consisting of 10 people they are
arriving to Tehran there are other
experts who are on the ground why is the
scene being bulldozed why do we have
polled Isis are they clearing the
evidence I mean normally I'd pick up the
evidence in Madison area this is
absolutely absurd the the hard evidences
are there the black box has been found
the voice recorder has been found and in
fact there are a number of reports that
have been as you know when a plane want
to depart there are technical reports
from the engineers to verify the safety
and safety of the plane these are on the
ground so nobody can rush to a judgement
with the prime minister or foreign
minister or a reporter or anybody else
this is a quite technical issue and it
has a procedure annex 13 of the ICO
Convention as cleared that what is the
procedure to go to this issue and find a
conclusion nobody should in fact allow
himself to have a rush judgment to these
things that as you said the victims and
the families of victims or in fact over
vent and we should not be adding to
their anxieties which
be very careful they say this has a
humanitarian aspects and we should
respect the families of the victims to
have a calm environment until we have a
clear conclusion on the ground I must
put this to you ambassador with all due
respect someone listening might see this
as an ambassador for a government for
him it's just simply too embarrassing to
admit that they've shot down a plane
with 83 of their own nationals on board
and therefore engage this is an absurd
conclusion from your sight it's not
someone listening Mike I have been very
clear I cannot accept that you as a
reporter can make a judgement on a very
technical issue and you're accusing in
fact a lot of accusations against my
country I'm telling about someone
listening or what I have explained my
explanations and your position is
absolutely unacceptable what's your
message to Boris Johnson who's already
completed the same things to be the
worker the same thing the missiles he
can't he has no access to the hard
evidences we can not rush to a judgement
you should be careful and you should be
patient until we have a conclusive in
fact report by the experts the Canadian
team is arriving Tehran Ukrainian team
is already there we have all experts on
the ground we have the black box we have
all the hard evidences and this should
be judged by the experts on the ground
full stop
how long will that take I don't know can
we talk about the situation that
possibly led to this the assassination
of Qasim sulemani and the missile
strikes that happen in response can we
be confident that Iran's response to
that it's another set in relationship
between two these two things you say
that this is it in relation with the
assassination of general Soleimani I
cannot accept this do you have any
evidence now I'm saying possibly one
thing let's take ad with so
possibilities there could be so expect
relations be very careful they need
should play a very constructive role
they should not agitate the people they
should not allow the people would be
killed more more than it is necessary we
should be very careful I have made my
position very clearly when Sky News
unfortunately had a very wrong statement
unfortunately in some of the media or
publishing unreliable news these these
days we should be very careful I think
we should be value the lives of the
innocent people and we should not be
adding to the provocations
well let's reframe that question the
assassination of Qasem Soleimani has led
to a response from Iran can we become
further that that's it the Trump
administration says that Iran is backing
down will we see any more retaliation
from your government is - what happened
to your revered commander we don't care
about the u.s. u.s. reaction we were us
assessment we have said when we
retaliated in act of self-defense we
said that that would be the action by
Iran in in accordance with the charter
of the United Nations to have a
self-defense and we have not devised any
other attack against the US bases and as
we have said so clearly Iran is not
seeking escalation or war there's also
concern about the Iranian nuclear deal
the jcpoa is it effectively dead do you
think no in fact we think that it's in a
very critical condition but that should
be that determination on all parties if
we want to in fact have the deal working
we think that the measures that Iran has
adopted would allow the deal still be
functioning well if there is a
determination we have opened the
possibilities for more negotiations and
diplomacy there are a lot of disk
here and there there are a lot of talks
about the country's concerned and still
we think that there is an opportunity to
save the deal it's been a very difficult
start to the year for your government
and for other governments in the region
you have been a seasoned observer of
Western governments you helped negotiate
that nuclear deal you know your
government very well how worried do you
think we should be about what's
happening in the region as I said we
should contain our emotions and in fact
we should be really trying to find
solutions for the for the differences
and conflict that we are
it could be ahead of us jcpoa is a very
fundamental diplomatic effort by the
countries concerned in fact to
strengthen peace and security at the
global and regional level unfortunately
the United States withdrew from the deal
and adopted a very dangerous path of in
fact maximum pressure policy against
Iran which has been cleared more than
before that is a faith policy and
unfortunately they are again emphasizing
on their wrong path and we are very
sorry again that President Trump
mentioned that they want to increase the
in fact the sanctions against Iran that
would not be helpful policy that would
be a wrong policy and as far as the
United States would not change its
policy we could be facing with the
uncertainties and even conflicts in
Delhi in the region so we hope that they
would come with the realities and change
their course
president Trump astonished everybody by
carrying out this assassination on a
general from another sovereign state if
America does anything more what will
Iran - how
you respond our measures always are very
measured and calculated we see what's
happening on the ground we would not
react to the emotions or tweets or
whatever we in fact we attach great care
to these incidents and we would be very
careful to see if there are wrong
policies on the ground we would
certainly react appropriately and
proportionately we hope that they would
have a lesson they we hope that they
would learn from from the lessons in the
past and in these days and really be
trying sincerely to to change the course
otherwise unfortunately as we have seen
there could be misunderstandings
misconceptions and even miscalculations
in the foreseeable future I hope that we
would give more certainty by changing
course I mean certain members of your
government have promised harsher revenge
are we going to see more retaliation
from either the Iranian government or
its allies in the region as I said we
have not designed or we have not thought
about any more retaliation at this stage
and we really hope that they would be
very caution to go to a path which would
be in fact adding to the conflict and I
think today in fact or escalating the
situation furthermore one last question
I think many people in Britain don't
understand who Qasem Soleimani
was on what he meant to the Iranian
people what was your reaction personally
when you heard what had happened to him
he was a national hero in Iran because
he was active during all stages of
resistance and a fight to gain
independence after the Islamic
Revolution and particularly during these
recent years because of his
in fact heroic actions on the ground to
fight against terrorism particularly -
and extremism in the region
he was so much supported by the people
so he was seen as a national hero and we
have we have lost a very beloved son of
our nation and as you have seen the
sentiment of the people has been very
extraordinary ambassador thank you very
much thank you